cette semaine en quête crise étudiante
du printemps dernier qui se cachait
derrière le masque des plus radicaux
j'essaye de créer ce moment l'enfant de
créer le moment où on va pouvoir se
réapproprier la rue fait des gens qui
sont fâchés qui décident de s'organiser
qui veut dépasser leurs limites les
limites établies de tête une balle en
charme et des mouvements d aj politique
[Musique]
bienvenue à cette sixième saison d'
enquête on se souviendra du printemps
2012 comme de celui de la contestation
étudiante et des manifestations dont la
violence a parfois surpris et choqué au
delà des arguments des uns et des autres
ce qui nous a surtout intéressé c'est de
savoir qui sont ces manifestants masqués
armés prêts à commettre des méfaits et
même a attaqué des policiers
et quel était leur rôle dans le
mouvement étudiant une de nos équipes
s'est rendu au coeur de l'action et a
obtenu un accès inédit à l'univers des
radicaux leurs propos sont controversés
mais permettent de comprendre qui se
cachent derrière leurs masques et
quelles sont leurs motivations
enquête sur les coulisses d'un conflit
qui a laissé de nombreuses cicatrices
la grève justement c'est une belle
opportunité en fait que justement les
gens puissent se radicaliser et
peut-être y avoir plus de gens dans les
black blocks
ne pas une radicalisation du mouvement
juniors des activités par des casseurs
10 face à la violence la police garde tu
face à la violente réaction suite on
veut faire comme une violence
révolutionnaire c'est le temple de se
lever et de dire que ces choses là ça
avec le pognon valeur ça reflète surtout
pas ce que nous voulons une société
dans toutes les révoltes dans tout les
mouvements de résistance quand les gens
sortent dans la rue on peut pas les
conflits re
[Applaudissements]
moi je pense que je te militants c'est
pas juste dans des moments de crise
sociale où je fini par sortir dans la
rue mais j'essaye de créer ce moment là
en fait de créer les moments où on va
pouvoir justement se réapproprier la rue
12 les manifestants se sont approprié la
rue ce printemps pendant des mois
montréal surtout été de théâtre
quotidienne de rassemblements parfois
monstre en soutien à la cause des
étudiants au plus fort du conflit une
manifestation sur trois a donné lieu à
une violence inhabituelle pour l'humour
il carton plein aux citoyens en otages
notamment parce que on paralyse le métro
il ya des problèmes de circulation les
commerçants voient leur chiffre
d'affaires baisser et on parle également
de la réputation de montréal sur la
scène internationale ont paralysé
vitrines cassées vandalisme
affrontements en règle avec les forces
de l'ordre
par moments montréal a eu des airs de
ville assiégée pour vous savez qu'à ça
ces gens l'objectif d'un fond c'est
justement de créer des images
les usagers du centre-ville souvent au
coeur de cette action
le black block jusqu alors que connut
énigmatique et réfractaire aux médias
comme nous l'avons appris à nos dépens
des mouvements d aj politique pour la
casse
j'ai justement le chaos à la base un
black bloc et souvent composés d'un
anarchiste qui prend une action directe
et illégale si nécessaire
on dit que c'est un groupe on dit que
c'est une organisation on dit que le
black bloc à des membres alors que c'est
complètement faux
deux vétérans aguerris ont accepté
d'expliquer leurs motifs
à condition qu'on change leurs voix ils
insistent pour dire qu'ils le font à
titre personnel puisque fidèles à leurs
convictions anarchistes
ils n'ont pas de leader il ya une
réunion où il ya 300 personnes habillées
en noir qui disent ok à cette manif long
on va aller puis on va faire un blabla
que c'est pas comme ça que ça se passe
c'est fait sur le tas c'est les gens
arriveront tout leur attirail et six ans
que la situation elle est propre et ça
ça avance ça bien en conséquence pour
former un black bloc un bloc n'existe
que le temps d'une manifestation
sa seule présence est un message au soir
il ya plein de cassard qui sont pas
politisés aussi les anarchistes sont pas
tous des casseurs c'est vraiment quelque
chose de spontané c'est des gens qui
sont fâchés qui décident de s'organiser
et qui veulent dépasser leurs limites
les limites établies dépassé les limites
et arthur b déstabiliser mais toujours
dans l'amour
il n'ya pas d'importance à voir mon
visage
c'est l'importance et la masse si le
fait de se masquer c'est qu'on devient
tous pareils on devient tous solidaires
les uns des autres
indépendamment de qui se cache sous les
masques c'est environ un mois après le
début du conflit que l'important
contingent noir drapeaux anarchistes à
la mer attire pour la première fois
l'attention des médias plusieurs se
demandent pourquoi il vient s'immiscer
dans le conflit étudiants on oublie
aussi souvent que c'est ces gens là qui
sont à la base même de la grève tous les
modérés qui ont voulu milité contre la
hausse des droits de scolarité au début
c'est les gens qui avaient une opinion
radicale qui disait ça pas de sens qu'on
est en train de faire à l'éducation
maintenant
2000 les chefs de gouvernement des
amériques se sont donné rendez-vous à
québec pour négocier leurs barrières
commerciales dans la rue c'est l'autre
barrière celle qui délimitent la zone
sécurisée qui est prise d'assaut les
québécois découvrent le black block un
groupe de militants altermondialistes
très radicaux préparer pour affronter
les policiers même cible même tactique
dans la lutte contre la hausse des frais
de scolarité
[Musique]
la ducasse à migration puis aller à la
racine du problème la racine du problème
c'est le système capitaliste c'est le
système néolibéral
puis c'est ce système là qui peut des
hausses de frais de scolarité radical
c'est l'image associée à la classe
l'enfant terrible des associations
étudiantes son discours anticapitaliste
en a surpris plusieurs
lors de la soirée de solidarité du 22
mars
dès le temps d'écrire collectés dans des
taux mais pas seulement c'est une
populaire c'est non
la classe texier reprochait d'entretenir
des liens secrets avec les radicaux on
me dit qu'un agent de cacher tu confonds
on n'était pas vraiment l'association
tente on est une espèce de lobby
socialiste obscures le matin d'avril où
nous avons rencontré gabriel
nadeau-dubois le modiste comité médias
de la classe discutent de l'actualité
dans un café de la rue saint denis à la
presse que l'avion se poursuivent et où
pascal breton s'étonner des positions
politiques de la classe c'est mal
connaître son histoire
le coeur de cette coalition est là c'est
l'association pour une solidarité
syndicale étudiante elle représente en
permanence 19 associations collégial et
universitaire qui revendique la gratuité
scolaire
ceci n'a jamais été cachés on est
content hausse des frais parce que on
est pour l'accident éducation parce
qu'on veut construire décidée de justice
sociale d'égalité qui ceci s'est passé
depuis notre fondation on était on est
des fondus dans la foule un sommet des
amériques
lassé permet à d'autres associations de
se joindre à elle pendant la grève
cette coalition temporaire lui permet de
plus que doubler son membership qui n'a
pas cessé d'augmenter depuis le début du
conflit
ainsi que d'augmenter sa force de frappe
[Musique]
avec ces paroles irrévérencieuse le
groupe mise en demeure est un peu
devenue le porte-voix des militants les
plus radicaux
nous on se pose des limites dans le
temps on se dit ok on peut pas aller
plus loin que ça parce que ça serait
abusée on se les mettre là puis on va
toujours une star plus loin ils sont eux
mêmes militants depuis le conflit de
c'est de là que viennent les paroles
controversées sur la ministre courchesne
vous ça fait bondir les premiers
ministres mais dès qu'on s'exprime en
dehors du respect ce n'est plus la
liberté d'expression
c'est de l'intimidation la violence a
utilisé depuis depuis très longtemps
depuis toujours en fait dans leur
manière c'est une forme de catharsis
pour les gens qui subissent des choses
qui scellaient leur crée des
traumatismes écoulé entre autres la
violence policière la violence juridique
la violence politique construit qu'on
pense que les gens subissent à tous les
jours il vend d'un anarchiste est aussi
exécutants d'une des associations les
plus militantes à l'université du québec
des 23 ans à l'époque engagé qui ont
profondément car souvent l'artiste
donc les gens qui vont à le cam souvent
dans le domaine des sciences humaines
dans sociaux en philo est aussi en
sciences politiques sont des gens qui
savent qu'il ya une espèce de lait nido
logique à ses militantes
allez savoir les quatrième membre du
groupe absent lors de cette entrevue
siège à l'exécutif de la classe n'est
pas un anarchiste parce que ça le
mettrait trop de troupes de dire celui
qui sur l'hexagone et quoi mais bon dans
la classe forcément et des anarchistes
ces gens là comme j'ai dit ils viennent
pas d'un égout sorte jusqu'en septembre
poser des actions puis retournent dans
leur ego après ces gens là mais il est à
longueur d'année forcément et qui sont
dans des organisations étudiantes dans
des groupes
après ça est ce que la classe appel est
lancé gré des black blocks mais sans
aucun sens ça ne fait pas de sens très
vite les manifestations s'organisent
spontanément sur les réseaux sociaux
sans l'intervention d'aucune association
étudiante mais le grabuge causés par les
actions des membres de la classe et son
refus de condamner la violence aux
scellés son image d'intransigeance
notre société ce n'est pas une société
en paix ce n'est pas une visite en paix
et des fois ça paraît pis c'est pas
anormal
viapass un petit vin ce n'est pas ce
qu'il veut mais c'est comme si on est là
en est elle en est enfoncée dans une
vision de de notre propre société où
tous les comptes tous les comptes
devraient se régler dans le management
lustres est tellement quitté engrenage
devenir bien glissé l'un sur l'autre
sans jamais grises et mais ça c'est une
apparente au fil des semaines la
violence des radicaux va devenir un
enjeu en soi
au point d'éclipser de vrais débats
[Musique]
après la pause dans les coulisses des
jeunes militants du black block ce
moment donné je me suis dit ok on serait
au printemps par les cornes qui on va
attendre ouvrir deux pareils
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
élite 11 kg des chaussures on en fait
des ratés tout à l'heure sur les
tendances et on n'est pas air devant
l'entrée séquence de l'humilité mais
qu'ils ont le retard et se garer
n'ajustez pas votre appareil
le compte rendu que vous entendez semble
peut être apte à retenir au présent mais
il remonte à 1969
[Applaudissements]
parlant de violentes manifestations pour
la francisation de l'université mcgill
secoue le campus pendant trois jours la
violence a toujours fait partie de
l'histoire du combat étudiants mais on
l'a un peu oublié
plus jeune moi je faisais partie d'un
mouvement étudiant n'a jamais jamais il
nous serait venu à l'idée nous de poser
des actes violents sur était impensable
impensable
la violence devient un enjeu le 7 mars
43 ans presque jour pour jour depuis des
affrontements de meggie un étudiant est
atteint par un projectile policiers et
les manifestants s'accusent mutuellement
d'être responsables
le mal est fait post grenier est devenu
le symbole
en guise de protestation la semaine
suivante la classe invite ses membres à
participer à la marche annuelle contre
la brutalité policière alors que la fecq
et la feuq prudente s'en dissocie
sachant fort bien que des actions black
blocks sont à prévoir
la police fait la force de frappe de
l'état et du capital
alors c'est clair que ça devient des
ennemis pour nous
l'invitation de la classe a aussi un
motif politique ses membres non
seulement et puis mes finances le
collectif opposé à la brutalité
policière depuis des années
en moins d'une demi heure la
manifestation déclarée illégale
les policiers sont pas légitimes de me
dire quoi faire on va rester ici
puis on veut se protéger on va se
défendre
on va défendre notre territoire qui la
rue pour l'instant on veut pas se faire
tasser
donc on va se masquer et on va
confronter les policiers qui veulent
nous tasser nous on attaque des gens qui
quant à eux recevront l'ordre vont nous
attaquer son discernement qui on le vit
à plusieurs reprises ce d'ailleurs
l'image qu'on retient de la soirée si
celle ci
[Applaudissements]
nous voulions savoir qui se cache
derrière le masque des jeunes
responsables de ce méfait qu'on a traité
ce soir là devant lui est ce que vous
aviez vu poser des gestes de ce genre là
pas du tout il a 17 ans est en premier
renier du sujet au début je veux pas
dire que j'étais pis elle la pige écrit
des slogans d'amour mais vraiment contre
toute forme de violence et plus
mouvement avancé puis on a mangé les
coups de matraque pour le cayenne +71
leur rentrer dedans
c'est une manifestation contre la
brutalité policière qui rendu un certain
point avec toute la haine la colère
tehran d'une manifestation contre la
police
le black block c'est aussi ces jeunes
entraînés par l'intensité du moment
surpris eux mêmes par la portée de leur
geste comme cette étudiante elle aussi
en première année de cégep qui a
participé à renverser la voiture face au
gouvernement
monsieur charest est complètement fermée
en fait on a l'impression qu'ils
pensaient comme une crosse du fac un
moment donné je me suis dit ok on
travaille on prend le taureau par les
cornes qui on y va à fond
au risque de paraître c'est un risque
mais je pense qu'il faut prendre des
risques dans la vie pour ce qu ont
revendu
deux cent cinquante huit personnes ont
été arrêtées de 15 mars dont plusieurs
mineurs c'est pas des dommages
collatéraux c'est juste des militants de
venir
c'est juste des gens qui à la longue
vont finir par s'éduquer parce qu'il ya
une éducation à aller en manifestations
il ya des règles à savoir pour
manifester
22 mars des dizaines de milliers de
personnes défilent pacifiquement dans
les rues de montréal
le black bloc et peu actif mais
n'apprécie pas notre présente
rassemblement impressionnant mais pas
utiles aux yeux des radicaux quand il
eut deux cent mille personnes dans la
rue le gouvernement jamais voulu
négocier jamais voulu s'asseoir avec les
étudiants
la violence atteint un nouveau sommet le
20 avril
des centaines d'étudiants un départ la
classe sont déterminés à empêcher la
tenue du salon sur le plan nord ces
images témoignent de la force de
l'affrontement
bien vite les sorties de garages et les
gens on peut en profiter pour rentrer
par cette porte forcée leur entrée à
l'intérieur mais position du jdd
repoussé et là c'était vraiment de
confrontation forcément des
démonstrations dans l'idée de renverser
la peur justement des gens qui vivent
dans une insécurité économique ou
alimentaires eux ils disent là-bas au
quotidien
quel est dans un moment précis d'une
manifestation où on renverse la peur où
on se met justement attaqué les
policiers ou attaquer des banques bien
on met la part sur ses jambes de
manifestants refoulés à l'extérieur est
victime d'un week-end on pense qu'il
faut que la société civile à ce moment
là bas sans moteur fonctionne en journée
normalement dus à la donc le but de
perturber la société civile sa ponette
violent c'est de réagir de résister à
cette forme de violence le
la confrontation vire à l'émeute une
demi-douzaine de personnes sont blessées
j'ai beaucoup de misère à trouver ça
seulement mon match gyan et à des gens
et des impatients qu'ils veulent qu'ils
ont décidé de se joindre à ce mouvement
le jour
cet habitué des black block a pris part
à l'émeute et ce n'est pas un jeune
étudiant les personnes qui font partie
de black blocks et vos infirmiers ces
deux gars qui vous sert votre café au
coin de votre rue seth godin clip vidéo
le tout à coup on en fait des démons des
jambes têtes brûlées qui ont qui ont
aucune autre ambition que de cassé des
fenêtres quand il ya une réflexion
politique très profonde derrière
visiblement secoué par les événements la
ministre consent à ce que la classe se
joignent aux négociations mais pose ses
conditions si d'autres gestes de
perturbations économico sociale sont
endossé par des associations étudiantes
ça signifie qu'elle s'excluent
d'elle-même de la table de discussion on
n'a pas le contrôle
j'ai même le permettre vous savez
diffusé en septembre de dire que quand
les fédérations et critiquant les
fédérations petites gens disent qu'ils
ont le contrôle
nous on essaie sincèrement pour l'avouer
l'inévitable se produit au lendemain
d'une manifestation impromptue
les négociations sont rompues
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
galvanisés plusieurs milliers de
personnes se réunissent place émilie
gamelin pour la deuxième nocturne qui
sera brutal
la première d'une demi douzaine de
vitrines et fracassé les manifestantes
des abruzzes le geste est sans
présentation l'auteur des scènes comme
celles ci sont venus plusieurs enfants
dans le conte sous la violence et contre
laissé parmi les manifestants dans cet
autre incident des manifestants de le
forcer un barrage policier et un jeune
homme essaie de dissuader
c'est un bon c'est une indication des
deux parties de labouheyre rencontre
travail ont rejoint m
[Musique]
les esprits commencent à s'échauffer les
médias n'ont pas été ménagé non plus
malgré les intentions pacifistes de la
majorité des manifestants je te passe
paix kfor de la forêt on voit ici le
journaliste pascal robidas et son
caméraman se faire bousculer et on me
disait j'ai jamais vu ça j'ai moi ça
fait 28 ans que je parle ici j'en ai
fait des manifestations à ma carrière
c'est la première fois que je vois des
médiaux accompagnés d'agents c'est que
j'étais
ça apporte rien notre cause se marier je
sais plus de colère ça fait plus
provoquer les policiers
ça nous fait perdre l'appui de la
population donc selon moi c'est ce que
je comprends pourquoi mais je trouve pas
que c'est quelque chose de positif à
faire
[Applaudissements]
charlotte gants des manifestaient
calmement ce soir là mais se trouvait à
l'épicentre d'une réaction policière
musclée
on s'est retourné en mêlant là on ne
fait rien on fait rien on veut s'en
aller comme réponse on s'est fait
bousculer on s'est fait jeter à terre
puis moi je me suis retrouvé sur le dos
j'ai reçu des coups de pied dans le dos
des manifestants sont voler en éclats
les vitres du poste de police du
quartier sam est un paquet des gens qui
ont patiné viennent de la spvm se
comprennent
s'appuyant sur un titre là on sentait
dans un état policier
on sentait qu'on pouvait rien faire on
pouvait vraiment rien faire du tout le
donc oui c'est compréhensible
c'est sûr ça s'encourage les actes de
violence après sun on va charger les
amis à oublier pas mais on eu ces
critiques en les entendant les entendus
pour ne modifié nos façons de faire
alain simoneau et les chefs du poste des
quartiers d'été ce sont les titres de
soudure ou qui ont été fracassées ce
serait dangereux puis vente est curieux
c'est chose d'autre chance de faire ses
joueuses et puis les pas ici sont formés
cas que cette affaire une dispersion
notre objectif nous sommes cette fois le
rétablissement donne dans les meilleurs
délais avec le moins de dommages
collatéraux mais il peut en arriver
c'est clair
[Applaudissements]
de nouveaux incidents vont encore sur
deux minutes et confronter les policiers
à d'autres acteurs de la gauche radicale
[Musique]
après la pause dans les coulisses
communiste dans le fait que moi qui
m'ont fait c'est dans le top 100 europe
et ailleurs ça me tente pas la réalité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au fil des semaines le masque symbole de
solidarité pour les manifestants à
paraître aux autorités comme un signe de
la violence denis contre le projet de
règlement municipal visant à l'interdire
attire des opposants devant l'hôtel de
ville
le groupe s'engage à peine dans la rue
qu'une arrestation a eu lieu sous nos
yeux la jeune femme n'avait pas le droit
d'être masqué
elle s'appelle cagna du bourg à 20 ans
et affiche résolument son appartenance
au parti communiste révolutionnaire qui
comme son nom l'indiqué est partisan de
la lutte armée
jacques un pote et j'essaye de m'en
sortir j'essaye d'avoir une vie j'aurais
été vraiment de la rencontre des
conditions objectives gens qui font que
c'est presque impossible de sortir de la
pauvreté parce que je te fais c'est
l'équivalent classes sociales de ce
pauvre ex aussi que tu peut si
facilement augmenter
tania est connu des policiers pour son
implication dans un violent incident
survenu l'année dernière lors de la
marche du 1er mai des manifestants armés
de bâtons se sont battus avec des
policiers pour empêcher l'arrestation
d'un camarade
dans le fait qu'ils voient qu'ils vont
faire c'est dans le deux autres ça me
tente pas de se fermer ta gueule sale
temps pour sa part regretté
les policiers disent avoir craint pour
leur vie la folle d'une violence extrême
qui attentaient sans l'ombre d'un doute
à notre vie la plupart essayer de nous
poignardé à la gorge
avec le bout de leurs bâtons j'ai
vraiment le sentiment que ses côtés ont
gagné la partie
[Musique]
il considère qu'on est des dangereux
vous mais je j'ai déjà répondu à l'ats
des policiers que oui je le suis parce
que moi je travail à abattre le
capitalisme
patrice legendre était dans la mêlée lui
aussi c'est un ex leader étudiant es un
militant communiste de longue date a
lancé nécessaire la violence existe la
violence politique existe
patrice legendre à une quinzaine de
procès à son actif principalement pour
avoir troublé la paix n'est fait ou
votre fille trouvée coupable
une seule fois on peut pas dire la
société est pourri on peut pas dire les
exploiteurs sont ceux ci puisse en tenir
ce qui est autorisé ce qui les gars
c'est ce policiers sont blessés dans
l'affrontement du 1er mai 2011 dont deux
qui subissent une commotion cérébrale
le spvm déclenché une enquête baptisée
du nom de gama pour get des activités
des mouvements marginaux et anarchistes
les suspects font l'objet de
surveillance et de perquisition est la
base de tout
dans la lutte des classes c'est
d'imposer le respect à l'adversaire
gamin s'est intéressé à la maison norman
de thoune le coeur névralgique du
mouvement révolutionnaire ouvriers c'est
ici que se prépare la révolution ce que
le club parvient à développer
l'expérience de combat de tout le peuple
au québec parce qu'un s'inscrit dans la
durée même durée combatif la bagarre du
premier nid elle a donné lieu à quatre
arrestations dont celle de tamié du beau
et de patrice legendre et on fait des
enquêtes le soin de gamme à la grc
arrêté à noah mettra sa - pendant des
semaines et des semaines et c'était une
évidence que ils voulaient empêcher en
particulier ma présence dans la
manifestation du 1er mai 2012
les communistes révolutionnaires étaient
quand même compter du black block à la
marche du 1er mai de cette année la
manifestation organisée par la
convergence des luttes anticapitalistes
la clac prend une ampleur exceptionnelle
dans la foulée de la grève étudiante
j'ai beaucoup d'étudiants qui avaient
une approche assez radical puis se sont
radicalisées plus avec la grève ont vu
la répression ont vu le discours vides
des politiciens qui respectait pas du
tout et nous dans nos réseaux dans les
gens autour de nous dans nos milieux
c'est sûr que plus en plus de gens qui
adhèrent à des idées plus radicale les
manifestants ont dû migrer sans ce jour
là et peu de patience envers nous
[Musique]
la convocation lui qui pose ici sont
inévitables 1er mai ce qui est arrivé
c'est qu'on a collé et envoyée des
jambes livebox nouvelle vie étaient très
nombreux on les a connus ce pas de la
provocation là on va vraiment la
fonction de chez dalloyau la source du
problème où se sont arrêtés au coin
d'une université de sainte-catherine
ils ont vraiment arrêté est d'ailleurs
décidé c'était l'affrontement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est toujours le même débat sur la
violence et pour des gens cassé une
vitre c'est très violent
pour nous c'est plus violents à laisser
quelqu'un dormir dans la rue et la grève
étudiante
qu'est ce que l'on fait c'est de
déplacer le niveau de confrontation
les chefs syndicaux que ce qu'ils font
ils comme sur la table c'est
inadmissible mais ils n'agissent plus il
ya pas eu de combat syndical depuis très
longtemps
les étudiants déplacés cette espèce de
deux mouvements le quai purement
symbolique et je suis d eau logique dans
des conférences de presse ont fait une
vraie lune
trois jours plus tard la violence
atteint son comble au congrès du parti
libéral 1 victoria ville
pourtant tout avait si bien commencé aux
alentours de 18h viserait plusieurs
milliers de manifestants venus partout
au québec sont partis du stationnement
d'un centre commercial pour se rendre
ici à l'hôtel le victorin ou quelques
lignes les manifestations tous les coups
francs ici certains casseurs ont lancé
des pierres de cette grosseur c'est en
fait des bouts de trottoir que l'on pas
casser sur le sol que laura s'est par la
suite
l'affrontement d'une rare intensité vers
3 heures il fait dévisser graves chez
les manifestants
ça reste des actions de désobéissance
civique sont parfaitement le web mais
faut arrêter de toujours réduire cette
frange très radicales y ait des gens
pour radicaux qui un jour se réveille
qui se disent moi j'en ai plus le cas
aujourd'hui
la classe des zones venir sur certaines
actions qui ont eu lieu à victoriaville
aujourd'hui j'aimerais dans un premier
temps bien sûr invité les étudiants au
calme pour nous c'est des actions que
nous condamnons vertement en demandent
encore fois aux étudiants d'aller
manifester de façon pacifique
geof j'ai vu qu'on était choquée par
plusieurs images ans qu'on a vu le
marathon de 22 heures de négociations
mène à une entente fragile qui s'écroule
quelques jours plus tard le projet de
loi 78 déclenché sursauts de violence
et un appui de taille à la grève dans la
population qui exprime sa colère par un
grand concert de casseroles pacifique
[Musique]
bonne nouvelle je pense que moi la façon
plus festives je reconnais l'hyboria les
deux dans les deux derniers jours et
cassation festing de faire les choses
non infiltrés par des casseurs mais
quand le ministre bachand et rosazia que
lui pour se les casseroles c'est la
preuve qu'il faut aller plus loin
[Musique]
après la pause dans les coulisses de la
police
un des témoins de vraiment des
débordements c'était assez déçu j'ai
vécu à la fusée routière qui était dense
et intéressant directement des policiers
puis les badauds aussi parce que
wehrmacht
[Musique]
en édition spéciale fine et le mouvement
de contestation continue de s'amplifier
le collectif anonymous s'est vite dans
le confit peuples du monde libre
anonymous nous invite à pau les côtés le
grand prix de formule un du canada
à la veille du grand prix les autorités
sont déjà sur les dents à cause d'une
vague de colis suspect qui vise entre
autres des ministres ainsi que le
premier ministre charest au jour j la
convergence des luttes anticapitalistes
la clac at elle à son tour à perturber
l'événement est vraiment le
turbocapitalisme comme on dit un
événement qui fait venir les plus riches
de la planète qui polluants qui est
misogyne qui fait dépenser de l'argent
dans des choses complètement inutile à
l'aube la police neutralisent plusieurs
radicaux dont la militante étudiante
yalda khadir par une série
d'arrestations sa surprise cette avocate
qui représente plusieurs des ares it on
les arrête ça ça va c'est le travail des
policiers
ce qui m'a bouleversé ce matin là c'est
la manière dont les gens ont été arrêtés
spectaculaire ce sont des manières que
les policiers utilisent pour arrêter les
gens dans des contextes écrire
[Musique]
le banquet d'ouverture qui coûte 1000 $
le billet est au profit des hôpitaux
pédiatriques
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi participer à une manifestation
illégale 78,54 se dessèche la mémoire
des manifestants s'habille en noir et se
masquer quelques centaines d'entre eux
sont rapidement encerclés
allez simoneau a commandé la majorité
des opérations de maintien de l'ordre
depuis le début du conflit
la police procède à une demi douzaine
d'arrestations dans le groupe retenu
captif
simplement nous dit pourquoi il ya eu
intervention si rapidement parce qu'il
n'y avait pas de grabuge leur une source
de danger d'anciennes intérieur présente
rang du groupe 5 kaurismaki et à masquer
le moulin est un masque et bien au nord
soudan geste représente une menace éclat
policiers envisagent de procéder à
l'arrestation du groupe coo couple j'ai
des motifs que j'aimerais qu'on forme
tout d'abord on faisait une robe d'une
station des garçons passent pas
s'asseoir et bien pensante la stratégie
des arrestations isolé et m'écoutent et
le suffi à stopper les trouble-fête
la manifestation est inégal avoir
augmenté que vous disperser sans club
allait arrêter bout d'environ une heure
les manifestants sont donc invités à
quitter les joues policiers et
manifestants auront un nouveau rendez au
plus tard dans la soirée
[Applaudissements]
si j'avais un conseil à des arrestations
dans des corps ensemble c'est la
première fois qu'un corps de police
municipal au canada est confronté à
pareil défi en six mois
le spvm a dépensé plus d'un million et
demi de dollars en fournitures de toutes
sortes et 11 millions et demi en temps
supplémentaire sinon ici
tana comme ça oui je vois première fois
aussi que son centre de commandement
situé au quartier général reste en mode
opérationnel aussi longtemps ces
officiers participent discrètement ou
décisions prises sur le terrain je mange
ou un caillou je me fais beaucoup c'est
je me fais pas rien on est bien
conscient et pourquoi le maire d'issy
les décisions des policiers ont souvent
été durement critiquée entre autres
celle d'arrêter 518 personnes dans la
nuit mouvementée du 23 mai les détenus
sont restés mais lier pendant sept
heures dans des autobus de faire une
activité de dispersion à 4 est urgent
brutal violent orage
on avait eu vraiment des poches
puisqu'on aurait eu à travailler là
encore en situation de violence pour
nous c'est important de d'arrêter
l'action l'activité
l'action en repli du fait cents à
l'ouverture voudra en prix des
manifestants dont tu sais la retordre
aux policiers
[Applaudissements]
à lessines ont laissé un viennent prêter
main forte
[Applaudissements]
les murs se sont mis de la partie
maintenant que tu protèges ton vote car
aucune organe génital gonna try to have
is ci comprennent qu on est présent pas
en présence de mix entre les personnes
nues
déjà qu'ils étaient dans sud ouest mais
aussi des gens qui étaient de
manifestations nocturnes dont nous on
est plutôt mon désir est nul
les vrais douloureuse autre américain
quelques affrontements vont marquer la
soirée et seront de courte durée
je m'en sers
on attendait ça
la princesse anne
21h30 les calmer des gens revenus
peut-être parce qu'on vient de serre et
ont été témoins de vraiment des
débordements c'était de lancer des
fumigènes des pierres utilisées
haussière qui était l'ancien région
directement des policiers puis des
badauds aussi particulièrement alain
simoneau aime rappeler que la grande
majorité des manifestations s'est
déroulée de manière pacifique
malgré les éclairs de violences
diffusées rogers garde on aura toute une
nuit
1 heure et demie c'est fini alors que
kaka déjà spontanée comme au capitaine
nécessaire la décharge les radicaux ou
pas c'est celle de dénoncer le travail
des policiers
le groupe mise en demeure est
directement concerné trois des quatre
membres
yvan laban anarchiste js le tueur et
allez savoir font face à des accusations
criminelles
en brûlant toute la ville mais arrêtez
nous on s'en fout on s'est donné rendez
vous tous nos amis sont en prison
plusieurs dizaines de militants sont
accusés pour leur implication présumée
dans des actions de perturbations à cela
s'ajoute selon le spvm paul waide de
2000 arrestations pendant les
manifestations au fil des mois les
radicaux ne crois pas que la violence
inouïe au conflit ça fait une différence
fondamentale et s'est même pas
l'avantagé radicaux en fait c'est
toujours à l'avantagé des modérés que la
violence au lieu parce que c'est
toujours les mots d'eric pourrons dire
si vous voulez que s'arrête le saccage
de négocier avec nous puis nous une fois
qu'on sera plus dans la rue les gens qui
sont radicaux ont rompu une masse
critique qui leur permet de poser ses
actions de la violence a aussi un coût
une et des blessés dont on ne connaîtra
jamais le nombre précis et dont chacun
ses responsables le camp adverse
après sept mois de lutte et la promesse
d'un décret ministériel annulant la
hausse des frais de scolarité les deux
grandes fédérations étudiantes ont
annoncé la fin du conflit alors que la
classe qui vise toujours la gratuité
scolaire s'engagent à réduire ces moyens
de pression
le printemps étudiants appartient
désormais au passé mais laisse en
héritage une nouvelle génération de
et à faire ce jeu 14 cas tant que je
capte la révolution humaine jusqu'à fin
2010 dans le fond ce qu'elle est je
pense pas l'avoir lemay
rien
[Musique]
si vous voulez nous contacter consultez
notre site internet à l'adresse suivante
vous pouvez faire vos commentaires et
vos suggestions et revoir nos reportages
pour connaître notre démarche
journalistique je vous invite à
consulter mon blogue
veuillez prendre note qu'en quête et
rediffusée le dimanche à 18 heures sur
le réseau de l'information
[Musique]
la semaine prochaine enquête
à quelques jours de la sortie de prison
de vito rizzuto comment le visage de la
mafia canadienne a changé et le mans qui
est le plus fort respecté le mode real
est temps je rapporte denquête la police
italienne fait état de l'existence en
ontario donné ce clan de la 'ndrangheta
7 à toronto et 2 attendu baie des
canoubiers ils ont infiltré l'économie
surtout dans la construction des soupes
économique et sur l'aspect shalit à
l'alhambra
merci d'avoir été là bonsoir et la
semaine prochaine
[Musique]
où